.
HAVE A BEAUTIFUL WEEKEND.
IT'S BEEN A PLEASURE.
♪ ♪
>> Raymond: I AM
RAYMOND ARROYO INFER
LAURA INGRAHAM INGRAHAM.
THIS IS A SPECIAL EDITION OF
"THE INGRAHAM ANGLE."
WE HAVE A BIG SHOW FOR YOU.
FLORIDA GOVERNOR RON DeSANTIS
WILL REACT EXCLUSIVELY TO
BIDEN'S DIVISIVE AND FRANKLY
DARK SPEECH ABOUT AMERICA AND
LATER I'LL GO GOLFING WITH
ACTORS MARK WAHLBERG, KEVIN
DILLON, BOXING GREAT SUGAR RAY
LEONARD AND EVANDER HOLYFIELD.
YOU'LL NOT WANT TO MISS THE
HIJINKS.
STICK AROUND.
FIRST IT APPEARS THAT
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS AWAKENED
FROM HIS HELLISH FEVER DREAM OF
LAST NIGHT.
HIS NIGHTMARISH SPEECH WHICH
LOOKED LIKE HE'D EITHER WANDERED
ONTO THE SET OF TRIUMPH OF THE
WILL OR INTO AMSTERDAM'S
RED LIGHT DISTRICT, IS ALL OVER
NOW.
TODAY HE HAS NO MEMORY OF IT.
WATCHING ALL OF THIS RECALL THAT
MOMENT AT THE END OF THE MUSICAL
1776 WHEN JOHN ADAMS PROWLS
INDEPENDENCE HALL IN
FRUSTRATION.
>> IS ANYBODY THERE?
DOES ANYBODY CARE?
DOES ANYBODY SEE WHAT I SEE?
>> Tammy: BIDEN WOULD PROBABLY
CALL ADAMS AN EXTREMIST BUT IS
ANYBODY THERE?
DOES THE PRESIDENT EVEN KNOW
WHAT HE SAYING?
YOU DECIDE.
I'M NOT GOING TO COMMENT.
YOU WATCH.
>> THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY TODAY IS
DOMINATED, DRIVEN AND
INTIMIDATED BY DONALD TRUMP AND
THE MAGA REPUBLICANS.
AND THAT IS A THREAT TO THIS
COUNTRY.
>> I DON'T CONSIDER ANY
[INDISTINCT]
>> DONALD TRUMP AND THE MAGA
REPUBLICANS WERE PRESENT AND
EXTREMISM THAT THREATENS THE
VERY FOUNDATION OF OUR REPUBLIC.
MAGA REPUBLICANS ARE DESTROYING
AMERICAN DEMOCRACY.
>> Raymond: CLEANUP ON
PENNSYLVANIA AVENUE.
WHOEVER PUT THE PRESIDENT UP TO
THIS SHOULD BE FIRED.
MY SUSPICION IS THAT AFTER THE
FEROCIOUS BACKLASH TO THE
SPEECH, THE STAFFERS RESPONSE OR
BIDEN HIMSELF MADE THE DECISION
TO BACKTRACK.
EVEN THE RATINGS PROVE WHAT A
BUST OF THE SPEECH WAS BUT HE
DID CONFIRM WISE 75% OF
DEMOCRATS IN A RECENT CNN POLL
QUANTO CANDIDATE OTHER THAN
BIDEN IN 2024 AND WHY HIS
APPROVAL IS